. We are potentially minutes, if not hours, from
hearing what is expected to be a list of 100
pardons from Donald Trump. We don't know
as of this moment whether Trump will try to
pardon himself, whether he will issue a blanket,
preemptive pardons for his children or son in law
or Rudy Giuliani at this moment of recording.
And this may change within an hour or within a
couple of hours. We don't have that information.
We know Trump is expecting to pardon about 100
people today. However, we have in the background
an insane story alleging that Rudy Giuliani,
Donald Trump's lawyer, I don't know if he's still
technically his lawyer. It's never been clear.
It hasn't been clear for months. Rudy Giuliani is
being accused of selling pardons by Trump for two
million dollars. Now, the background on this
is that for some time, we've heard rumblings
of those who were collecting consulting fees,
I guess you would call them in order to lobby
for a pardon from Donald Trump. And now
specifically, Rudy's name and the cash figure of
two million dollars is being associated with this.
We know that there have been folks, for example,
who have said, listen, if you give me 50 grand,
I'll try to get you a pardon. And if I succeed,
you give me another 50 grand. A one time
top adviser to the Trump campaign reportedly
actually collected that 50 grand in order to try
to seek a pardon for a guy named John Kiriakou,
who's a former CIA officer convicted of illegally
disclosing classified information. And Kiriakou
is he says it agreed to the 50000 thousand
upfront fee and a 50000 performance bonus. So
a hundred grand for a pardon? Not too bad, 50
grand even if it fails. OK, that's, I guess,
the risk you're willing to take if you're paying
for pardons. But this is where the story gets very
interesting. As reported by The New York Times,
Mr. Kiriakou, who opted to go with the 50 down 50,
if we get it. A payment plan, was also offered
to pay two million dollars to Rudy Giuliani
for what was claimed to be an offer to secure a
pardon. So sort of like, you know, you go to get
a car and you can trade in a car or not, and you
can lease or you can finance. And if you lease,
you could do 24, 36 months. And maybe you want
10000 miles a year or 12 or 15. There were pardon
plans available. You could choose to do 50 down
50 if we get one. That's one possibility. Or you
could go with someone presumably believed to be
closer to the president, Rudy Giuliani, who just
wanted two million flat and I guess was saying you
can definitely get the pardon this way, although
there's never really a guarantee of anything
when Donald Trump is involved. And of course,
the immediate question is, could this possibly
be legal? And I hate to say this, but it's not
completely clear in the sense that certainly a
president selling pardons would not be legal,
that that would be against the law, not whether
you could prosecute a president for it. That
is certainly a question mark. And there are many
people who say you can and others who say it would
be very difficult. What we're talking about here
can all be couched under legal representation. And
when Rudy Giuliani was confronted, the so the FBI
was alerted, Rudy selling pardons for two million.
And when Rudy Giuliani was confronted about
it, Rudy didn't say that's crazy. I don't know
anything about two million or anything like that.
I haven't talked to anybody who wants a pardon.
Rudy Giuliani's response was I challenge the
characterization of what it was I was offering.
And that tells you everything you need to know. I
challenge the characterization and will even look
at this key part from the New York Times. Mr.
Kiriakou was separately told that Mr. Trump's
personal lawyer, Rudolph Giuliani, could help
him secure a pardon for two million dollars.
But Mr. Kiriakou rejected the offer. But an
associate fearing that Mr. Giuliani was illegally
selling pardons alerted the FBI. Mr. Giuliani
challenged this characterization that denial is
barely a denial. You're challenging the way it is
characterized. And what obviously is going on here
is that legal services are being offered. I'm sure
that the way this is being framed is Rudy says,
listen, I offer legal services, which include
representing your request for. A pardon? Between
the lines, it's I talked to Trump every day
and I have influence over him and I feel really
strongly that I can make sure you get a pardon.
But what I'm offering is legal representation.
I will write the letter. I will represent you in
any back and forth. I will represent the PR and
public facing part of this. And I estimate that
my legal fee is going to be two million dollars.
And I take that as a retainer up front. Is
that illegal? No, probably not. I mean, this
is one of those things where by the letter of the
law, that's probably not against the law. And so
the move by Rudy Giuliani, of course, is I
challenge the characterization. It is insane
that this is what's going on. And by the time
you listen to this, we may know who's on the
pardon list. We're expected to know at some
point today. We will certainly cover it for you
on tomorrow's program. The after the fact will
be figuring out who paid what for the pardons.
And again, technically, it may be who paid for
consulting services related to how to best ask
for a pardon. I don't expect to see anybody go
down for selling pardons because ultimately,
the only person who can really sell the pardon
is Trump himself, because he's the one doing the
pardoning. I don't believe it's Trump who's
doing it. It's clearly people around him.